right now the staff at this garage and
Constance have their hands full they're
flat-out repairing all the cars that
customers drop off here
Renee Mumma is one of them he's been
living on the Swiss side of the German
border for a years now when his car
breaks down he shows up here to get it
fixed more than half the German garages
customers are Swiss it's simply a
question of price repairs here are at
least 30% cheaper than in Switzerland
it's cheaper here than in Switzerland or
Italy and so I let my wallet do the
talking
you show off my importantly more Swiss
customers have been looking to buy new
cars here in Germany recently but it's
repair work that accounts for the lion's
share of inquiries the hype comes from
lifting order starting from the weak
euro or the strong franc depending on
your perspective created a lot of hype
that was back in 2010 2011 and 2012
things settled down a bit after the
franc was pegged to the euro but right
now after the changes were again
enormous ly popular with the Swiss and
many Swiss also travelled to Constance
to do their shopping it's a tradition
dating back centuries and whenever the
Franck surges against the euro there are
more Swiss to be found in downtown
Constance we've noticed the effects
quite markedly we've had to bring in
more stuff and we've had to put on more
stuff to sell it again and a lot of
other retailers say the same thing it's
annoying of course there are more people
but it doesn't get on my nerves
for the tones retailers all the Swiss
visitors are a blessing revenues from
the cross-border train keep many of
constants as small retailers are float
but the Swiss shoppers also have their
downside for years now we've had huge
numbers of visitors an influx born of
purchasing power up to eight thousand
cars come here every weekend from
Switzerland
and we've been debating what to do about
all that traffic for years now 8,000
additional cars are bound to leave their
mark on a city with a population of
80,000 during the week the traffic
closed smoothly at the Swiss German
border crossing but it's a different
story on the weekend the town is trying
to find new ways to cope with all those
visitors visitors who remain of course
most welcome